Y efectivamente,
lo que está en juego en este en este momento,
en este país es entre 1 modelo excluyente
que plantea 1 política cortoplacista,
1 política que no es capaz de
de responder a las aspiraciones
de esta sociedad,
al ansia de avanzar por 1 sociedad más justa,
más equitativa y más soberana,
o 1 modelo cooperativo
que no es excluyente,
que no excluye a la Primera fuerza
política de este país
y pretende avanzar hacia 1 horizonte
de más igualitarista,
más progresista y más soberanista.
Eso es lo que está en juego en estos momentos,
y para avanzar hacia ese modelo político
es alternativa.
Es imprescindible
reforzar la opción política
de h Bildu, porque h Bildu representa
em ese mandato democrático
somos 1 fuerza política soberanista de izquierdas.
Y si este país VA a avanzar en términos soberanistas
y VA a avanzar en términos progresistas,
será porque h Bildu
lidere la la la política en este país